getting a visa to live in the Netherlands
as an American.
was it hard
and what did I have to do?
what kind of visa do I have?
I'm answering this with a video
because there's not enough room in the comments to
say everything.
it was extremely
easy to get a visa to live in the Netherlands.
all I had to do was upload a bunch of paperwork online.
Kevin had to upload um,
his proof of income and some other things.
you can find more info on ind dot NL.
it's also in English.
I'm on a partnership visa
where Kevin sponsors me as his partner,
but I can also work here.
and the visa is valid for 5 years
and then I have to renew it.
you can find more info on my blog.
scribble a dream com
actually wrote a whole blog post about the process
and it's called My Immigration Story.
so just go over to my blog
and let me know in the comments
if you have more questions and I'll try to answer them.